this is the first morning where we
haven't it hasn't been raining here in
Houston so that's good news for everyone
but there's still an unprecedented
amount of water in the rivers and
reservoirs across Houston it's
threatening to send flood levels even
higher the Attucks reservoir that's just
west of downtown here spilled over on
Monday for the first time ever in
history and that overflow is threatening
to inundate nearby neighborhoods record
or near record water levels are
straining other reservoirs lakes and
rivers david beg no is in Humble Texas
near the lake near Lake Houston
reservoir David good morning Nora good
morning let me start with some good news
the water is receding ten o'clock last
night this is where it was when we
showed up about two hours ago the water
was down to right here and in fact when
you look at the surgical hospital and
Humble which had water inside you can
now see concrete we didn't see that when
we showed up you mentioned the
reservoirs never before has the water
overflowed the reservoir but it's
happening now and officials are telling
people it could continue for weeks or
even months evacuees were arriving by
the truckload in Northeast Houston on
Tuesday grandparents children pets even
a deer once on drier ground miss Billy
didn't know what was happening next
where are you gonna go now their homes
Border Lake Houston and are now
accessible only by boat about 30 miles
upriver at Lake Conroe historic levels
have forced authorities to release water
at nearly the same rate as Niagara Falls
cell phone video shows the powerful
flood water rushing down the San Jacinto
River the force was strong enough to
sweep away an entire concrete barrier
along interstate 69 officials are
anticipating uncontrollable overflow at
two reservoirs west of downtown Houston
the water will eventually feed into
Buffalo Bayou that is the small
tributary that winds through Central
Houston and is now a sprawling body of
water with the rainfall still occurring
in downstream reaches of Buffalo Bayou
and tributaries
well is in discharge of water from
attics and Barker and it may still take
several days for it to receive officials
told people to get out now
when water breached a levee on the
Brazos River yesterday okay
but for many people getting out isn't so
simple somebody has caught the number
that was to come pick everybody up
yesterday they never showed up
Latika LaShawn Thomas flag down one of
our producers yesterday she and her two
daughters have been stuck in their
apartment in South Houston since Friday
they've run out of everything but not
faith no God is gonna see this do you
know what Latika reminds us she reminds
us that it's not just the people who
have water in their homes that we should
worry about Nora it's the people who
don't have water but haven't been able
to find food or fuel for the last three
days they are just as much in dire need
I'm glad you pointed that out David
thank you so much